[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
sick of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about at
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
a psychologist and author dr. Linda
Papadopoulos welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me
[Music]
it's great to have you here and before
we get started what we always like to do
is ask the guests to tell the viewers a
little bit about how they are where they
are who they are just a little
background to get them to know you sure
well I'm a psychologist I've like I
guess I've been really lucky in that I
got into psychology very very young age
and I've been able to kind of follow
sort of several passions around my
interests range from the mind-body
connection so I did a lot of work on
kind of psychoneuroimmunology and skin
and in the early days and I went off and
I did a lot of work kind of Jason's out
on body image the way that we look how
it affects how we feel that then let it
me into things like objectification
sexual ization so I did a lot of work
and policy work as well kind of advising
how the way that we portray each other
and understand those poor trails affects
our judgments the way that we behave and
then I've also gotten to do I guess some
some really kind of perhaps less
highbrow but really interesting stuffs
I've done a lot of media work where I
think it's been really lovely being able
to kind of take these concepts that you
normally write about in academic
journals to the to the public so I've
had you know several TV shows I've
written for popular magazines and as
well as my academic books I've written
lots of self-help books as well you have
your own podcast as well which were
talked about but actually before we
started the interview we sat down we
hadn't met before we started chatting
and it very quickly became apparent that
we are quite aligned in terms of what we
often talk about with you and so let's
just get straight into first of all one
of the things you know this is called
trigonometry and we briefly mentioned
that I was telling you this study that I
saw that telling giving people trigger
warnings actually Prime's them to be to
have a negative experience of whatever
it is and he was like yeah please please
ask me about that on the show so what
you want to say to us as a psychologist
about that if you think of one of the
things that we're doing cognitive
therapy right when someone comes in and
says look this is happening to mean it's
really bothering me one of the things
that we do is we look at erroneous
thinking so if I've come in and I've
said you know uh you know III don't like
stripes it may
you hear well Linda doesn't like me and
you know or she's being offensive and
she's being directly offensive now if
you were having therapy they'd be like
well maybe it's just that Linda had a
bad experience with strips maybe it's
nothing personal maybe before you kind
of personalize this and become triggered
by it maybe you need to check out with
Linda why she said that so in a lot of
ways these these trigger warnings lot of
ways kind of priming people to be
offended is the exact opposite of what
we do in CBT which is take a step back
and reevaluate that thought right if I'm
going out of my way to find something to
be offended about then I will be and
there's a value in being offended
because if I'm offended I can put myself
in the role of someone who's a victim
then they need to take care of me I can
get sort of some sort of I can get
social points because I've called you
out for being whatever being
unthoughtful I'm caring so there's a
reason why this happens and I think one
of the things that that I think we see a
lot of these days with regards to to
people feeling that vulnerability is
precisely because I think a lot of young
people grew up in a culture where their
parents got rid of obstacles they were
like snow plows so that a problem with
the teacher they went they spoke to a
teacher on their behalf they you know
they didn't like not being invited to
kids party they'd complain and they'd
speak to the mother and they can vanish
provided to the party a big part of
dealing with life is having the
resilience to come back and realize it's
sometimes [ __ ] happens not because
someone's out to get me but because
things happen and I have to find the
strength to overcome these things so I
just kind of feel that a lot of the way
that we're talking about trigger
warnings and language being dangerous
basically D skills people from being
able to cope with these things and I
certainly wouldn't want that you know
for my child or any of the young people
that I work with and you think this
behavior is addictive that once you
start and you cast your saya themself in
the role of victim you get this
attention you think just have hang on I
quite enjoy this whether consciously or
subconsciously well there's I think
there's a power in in
being being seen and being heard and
look I think there are some genuine
people that are victimized out there I
think it's important that we say that
and I think they should be able to speak
up and talk about it but I think intense
importance right if I bump into you I
didn't mean to bump into you then surely
that matters
right now the amount you hurt you know
if you really heard that that yeah that
matters too but the intent has to come
into it my kind of fear that it's very
rarely about intent it's very rarely
that I didn't notice you had this Drive
shirt on before I said I don't like
stripes I always enjoy when your fashion
sense gets I did show this to my
girlfriend yesterday and she just looked
at it and then walked out the room you
know when you're trying to pet a cat you
know so there we go
Laurel those stories listen to you
listen to this approval um do you think
social media has made this worse the
fact that you know we're all constantly
logged in all looking for approval we're
all looking for likes etc etcetera
etcetera
I I think it's um it's a huge part of it
I think yes they're looking for approval
and likes but I think also kind of the
distillation of one's ideology down to
their you know the most thoughtless
tweet right so yeah if you know surely
we're an amalgam of all of you know the
ways that we interact our interactions
are opinions everything else what
because I can look into your background
and come up with the one time that you
used you know whatever you know a word
in the wrong way or you re like
something you didn't think about and you
retweeted it I think these things mean
that we are walking on eggshells were
constantly so anxious of being
misunderstood because they're like we
said earlier there's there's something
in calling out people for being wrong so
we've got this very weird situation
where we want to be seen so we're
constantly kind of saying this is what I
feel about this and I have an opinion
about that but at the same time the rest
of us are kind of looking to call each
other out because there's a value in
that as well so like the kind of the
discourse isn't the healthiest we're not
kind of talking to get to a better place
of understanding we're talking to kind
of call each other out and see what we
hold
maybe you didn't see that in the right
way and then that you know then those
kind of Twitter were starting yeah do
you think it's it increases people's
narcissism using the social media yeah I
think it's inevitable that something
that the the that makes you think about
how you're seen in such a nuanced way
increases narcissism and and and I don't
mean that I mean it's actually really
kind of heartbreaking so I've been a
psychologist for many many years and so
even things that I see a lot of the way
they're depicted to me of change I do a
lot with eating disorders and you know
for for many years that the big thing
was a number right so I want to be this
swayed I want to be this size and then
more recently people are bringing in
sort of pictures from Instagram with
sort of hashtags like bikini bridge or
thigh gap or box gap which means we're
kind of standing outside ourselves and
looking in we're kind of you know self
objectifying now this self
objectification while there's a
narcissistic element there's also an
element that kind of belies incredibly
dangerous low self esteem because you
know not only am I looking myself
through my eyes but through the eyes of
you know everyone else that I feel is
looking at me and through their values
and through the way that they're going
to assess me so yeah I always say if I
was gonna create a an exercise for poor
self-esteem I tell people to take a
bunch of pictures of themselves look
through the ones that are like the least
awful then find that one and then spend
you know 20 minutes filter and get
thinking of a great hashtag then put it
up on social media then sit back and
wait for the likes and a 50 don't come
in the first 20 minutes take it down and
start over again that is literally an
exercise and you know and poor
self-esteem yet you know so many people
do it day in day out and this idea of
not being able to live up to your selfie
you know this discrepancy between Who I
am and who I'm projecting I think is
having a significant effect on mental
health because there's there's no
ability to rest from from what does
everybody else think about me that's
constantly there there's no Billy just
say well this is who I am and maybe this
can be okay
and I've always sorted
well the kind of part of your job as a
human being as you mature is to start to
get to a point where your self-esteem is
driven by what you think about yourself
like a kind of sense of who you are and
it seems like social media is taking
that away from us and kind of almost
exploring our vulnerabilities as human
beings would you say that we're
particularly vulnerable to social media
as humans well this is such an
interesting point so again if you look
at sort of human evolution
we've not evolved to kind of absorb the
opinions of thousands and thousands of
people ourselves right we tend to live
in sort of in groups and and there's
some research that attest the fact that
even the amount of friends that we have
should be no more than about a hundred
we just can't handle anymore that's how
we've evolved it works well so social
media is all about the numbers like you
say and so you know being able to
assimilate this kind of I mean there's
like bathroom doors anyone can write
whatever it is on the back but because
they're not in a little cubicle with a
smelly toilet they're there for everyone
to see it matters whatever's written
matters and if thousands and thousands
of people's opinions then the diversity
of the matter again that that's a recipe
for disaster because not only do you not
rest from it but you're never like you
say able to say do you know what this is
who I am this is the imperfect version
of Who I am in a while I think we all
want to you know self actualize and
reach our potential you know part of
that is saying I'll never play in the
NBA if I'm a certain height I'll never
have a singing career if I can stand out
or whatever it is and and being okay
with that and I think that's that's
harder when you know those goal posts
are always you know sort of changing
about who you ought to be and everyone's
telling you well you're not there yet
what do you think about what do you
think makes social medias so addictive
what is it specifically they designed it
that way why do we go into it so much I
even I do it even I do the first thing I
do when I wake up in the morning is
check Instagram yeah because okay this
is very interesting again so up until
relatively recently psychology has been
used to help people right so you have a
problem you've got a psychologist you
help them in the last sort of twenty
thirty years
psychology is slowly being
used to to persuade people there's
there's places called sort of persuasive
technology labs usually where you know
places where tech exists right so I
think Silicon Valley where our
psychology is being used against us so
for example I don't know um you guys
obviously Netflix right I love Netflix
I can't watch one show anymore I rarely
fun watching a series I can rarely turn
off and watch now the reason for that is
they know that if they start the next
one right away like they do I'm more
likely to stay they take away a barrier
if I can skip the intro I'm more likely
to stay they take away another barrier
because the metric for the success of
social media sites is time spent online
so they ensure and not because they're
able to thing any one of these social
media companies is bad or evil they're
just trying to to maximize their profit
maximize how successful they are so if
time spent online is what they want when
I'm devising whatever Instagram snapchat
Facebook I'm going to ensure what will
make you more likely to say well I know
that notifications well why you know um
there's something called variable reward
system you know like slot machines yeah
you know why they're addictive every
time you pulled it you know something
would come out there'd be not much to it
you'd get it when you wanted it but the
fact that sometimes it comes out every
three times you pull it sometimes it
comes out every five times means you're
much more likely to go back we know that
that's very basic human behavior now
that variable rewards system exists on
all social media sites it exists and
when you see that little notification at
the bottom it exists when you're gonna
get some sort of validation when you get
that you know the retweet it exists when
someone likes something we know that now
also there's gender differences here
right so if we look at the way that boys
and girls react differently we know that
boys tend to be much more apt to gaming
addiction why is that because we're
evolutionary perspective men are have
evolved to seek out competency
especially during those teen years young
boys now what does that mean that means
I want to feel like I'm getting good at
something now what better thing than if
I give you a game that I kind of think
ding ding give you a reward every little
while every delinquency I feel better
and I get that dopamine rush and I play
more so I get more of a dopamine rush so
that becomes quite addictive for girls
we're taught to seek out kind of that
social equity right do you like me am I
you know I have that equity do you enjoy
you know being with me and as a
consequence again those hearts those
likes are going to be very validating
and rewarding so you know behind your
phone this is not just a platform
there's you know there's dozens of
people with PhDs in psychology you know
way smarter than you know than the
average person in terms of how they
understand human behavior how they
understand themselves all you know
ensuring that you spend as much time as
possible on these platforms and you
think that there's anything that can be
done or what what what's going to be the
impact first of all of this if you
project it into the future and is there
anything we can do as a society maybe
legislatively to start to curb some of
these things yeah I mean III think it
will I think we're already beginning to
see so sort of gaming addictions already
accepted in places like Japan not not
yet in the in the States but I think
it's happening we know that we know that
again even from a psychological point of
view and you know self-harm which we we
tend to see quite a lot of it especially
with sort of adolescents and adults
we're beginning to see that in the
digital form so digital self-harm where
young people are bullying themselves
online anonymously now this is a new
thing and we're yeah you got to tell us
more so there's been cases where young
people have been horrifically bullied
online and as we know there's been you
know horrific cases where they've taken
their own lives or attempted to and what
we find now is in some cases certainly
certainly not all but in some cases
these young people will actually be in
such a low place that they create
another profile and they bully
themselves they call themselves stupid
or ugly or horrible and the premise we
believe because this is very new this is
not something we know you know we don't
have much data on but we believe it's
the same thing it's about it's about
showing the pain showing the the pain I
feel inside and externalizing it and
being able to deal with it so
you know all of these things are
affecting us and this is just mental
health cognitive health is being
affected as well we know that
Millennials now there's some studies to
attest to the fact that Millennials have
worse memories than seniors and we know
we know that because when you
consolidate a memory if you keep being
interrupted you're never gonna
consolidate that memory so try and
remember something when I keep you know
you keep hearing buzzing or pinging
you're having to reinsert anymore
there's a reason for this sleep
disorders huge problem they're on the
rise why because this blue light that
we're constantly on affects us sleeps
really important we believe that sleep
is one of the factors that is implicated
in depression so there's so much going
on and and I think kind of our tech has
outpaced our social evolution our
physiological evolution and we're trying
to play catch-up I'm what responsibility
do the social media companies have for
our mental health I mean is it simply
the fact that you know we're all
individuals and you know we need to be
responsible for ourselves or do they
need to take some responsibility for
essentially manipulating us and getting
us to engage in this addictive behavior
I think I think you know they do need to
take some responsibility you know it
can't be that everywhere else we have
regulation weigh the ads that kids see
you know the watershed remember the
watershed that was it yeah yeah
completely irrelevant now but there was
a reason we had the watershed right so
yeah some responsibility needs to be
taken I think the problem is is that the
way that our our governments are set up
to kind of regulate these things often
doesn't apply when you don't understand
these are set up you know we're not just
where they're domiciled but what they
actually do well I'm a publishing
company I just let people put videos on
my site you know so it's always kind of
well what do you actually do though if
you're if you're not taking you know
these videos are dangerous whose
responsibility is it is it you for
providing the platform or is it the
person putting up so we need to have
some serious conversations about this I
think government needs to come in with
some sort of better guidelines about
usage for young people especially for
kids and we are slowly getting more
information but again you guys need to
remember is sort of you know what
Facebook's a teenager you know snapchats
what seven eight
years old Instagram 910 Deena these are
all new so we're kind of trying to
figure it out but I don't think it's
good enough saying you know well you
know the Internet's the one place where
you're allowed to have no legislation or
no restrictions you know it seems
ridiculous to me that in every other
area of our lives we have at least some
semblance of guide guidance one thing
that I notice with social media is for
my days as a teacher is year on year
seeing children being less adept at
social interaction and obviously I've
never done a study on that but I just
always thought and then you saw them the
moment you gave their phones back at the
end of the day because we took the
phones off from at the start they would
turn left the moment they first they did
you switch on going whatever it is and
but you saw a lot of the time that
arguments would happen in a playground
not because there was antagonism not
because they you know there was there
was a bullying issue at times it was
simply because they didn't know how to
articulate their thoughts and listen to
one another and I found that terrifying
yeah yeah because it's practice right
you know that's that's how we learn you
know and we learn to read each other and
and speak and we do you know the nuances
of voice inflection everything it's
practice when you don't have that you
know of course it's going to be anxiety
provoking and we know that you know with
any anything in life the more you avoid
the bigger the problem becomes if I'm
afraid of social gatherings and I stop
going to them eventually you know it's
hard to get out of my front door at some
point because I've avoided avoided and
likewise with communication so I think
we definitely need to foster that you
know and I think the other thing that
you speak about young people I have such
an issue with kind of the age
segregation that happens right so that
you know the 14 year olds just speak
with other 14 year olds the Millennials
just with the Millennials there's
something important with you know the
quirky aunt or the the funny grandma
that you hang out with you know where we
had that I think now again because of
these connections which are wonderful a
lot of ways that we can have friends
around the world but I can literally you
know be so isolated and have these quote
unquote echo chambers not just in terms
of political views but also in terms of
the uniformity of the people I choose to
speak with and that in and of itself is
dangerous because the young people
you're worried about are speaking about
with other young people who are
optically fined
walking like that so you're the one
that's kind of a bit odd what are you
worried about two is fine right this
Sunday reminds me my own school well
well you mentioned a little bit about
boys and girls and how they think
differently and do focus on different
things there's no difference might stop
it well there we go that's exactly where
I was going to take this because even
the concept now that there's a
difference between men and women is
becoming a triggering issue for a
certain group of society or someone
who's worked and in helping couples and
things like that right so can you tell
us a little bit about what are the main
differences between men and women
psychologically and how that manifests
particularly with respect to
relationships I think we're still look
there there's physiological differences
right so the fact that there's a
y-chromosome means something we know
that men are significantly
over-represented in Cris in prisons
right we know sort of that that you know
aggression tends to you know or the
display of it we know that men commit
suicide more than women even the women
present with with depression more now
that might be the way that men are
socialized again one of my my biggest
pet peeves is that we we still I think
we're getting somewhere you know
somewhat better but I think we still
make more space for you know women's
mental health and men's mental health I
think men still feel more stigmatized
it's easier to show anger than sadness I
think the social norms around what's
expected of men and women although we're
trying to battle some of them still
remain I've got a you know a wonderful
friend who decided his wife makes more
money than him one had to stay home and
take care of the kids he stayed home
he's always making jokes about you know
how other dads are afraid of them you
know what to say to me she's like this
weird guy that stays home we're not sure
so you know you know there are there
differences around biology yes around
expectations yes around sort of you know
our chromosomes you know our hormones
and make us different of course they do
now you know I understand that there's
always a fear and talking about
difference because immediately once you
talk
difference the fear is then are you
gonna use my difference you know against
me so I understand you know where that
comes from but I think it's more
dangerous to be intellectually dishonest
and not talk about difference and not
have the conversations that matter to
ensure that both men and women are
treated as fairly as possible
you know with within the realms of what
it means to be you know a person living
in 2018 today kind of navigating all
these well they're given in
relationships I mean I've been married
for 14 years now we've had you know ups
and downs as you always do and one of
the biggest differences in terms of kind
of helping our relationship forward was
reading a men are from Mars Women are
from Venus this book by John Gray I'm
sure there's different people will have
different disagreements about particular
things about it but one of the things
that was very helpful in is helping me
understand my wife but also in helping
me understand myself and understand why
I'm doing certain things or why I'm
feeling certain things and I think
that's a potentially very big danger if
we tell me if you tell people there's no
difference between men and women when
there actually are differences then that
makes relationships more difficult
doesn't it well yeah I mean look I think
self-awareness and you know is key right
understanding why you behave the way you
behave and look yeah psychologists talk
about a biopsychosocial approach so we
need to look at you know are there
biological or straight you know does the
fact that you have you sort of a
different hormonal chemistry than your
wife will that make you process things
different you know if so how does the
fact size sociology does the fact that
you've been socialized differently mean
that you're going to use something
differently to your wife perhaps if so
how psychology now is this different is
this is there something within your
psychology you know maybe there is maybe
there isn't but again I think there's
something very important about not being
afraid to kind of just sort of look at
the good science that that's out there
and not fall prey and again look I know
it comes from a good place and you know
people you know absolutely who have been
oppressed whatever group sort of you
know should absolutely be able to fight
for their rights and and yeah you know
and we should all support them but I
think that can't happen to the detriment
of what we know for sure so
being that you know biology doesn't
matter is I think it's it's it's not a
fair our accurate statement do you think
there's it's in intellectual circles as
there's this dishonesty happening where
people feel that they have to parrot a
certain viewpoint because if they don't
they you know they could be seen to be
in inverted commas you know a bigger to
whatever else or have you ever felt that
pressure all in your career okay I try I
try and be honest with what I believe I
do I try and substantiate what I say I
think that's very important because I
think when you have science behind you
and you say you say then it's it's
easier having said that I think people
will often hear what they want to hear
you know and and yeah you know one
worries if yeah I think again because of
social media because of you know this
you know this kind of caricature ization
of each other and we don't believe in
each other it's oh I take this one thing
you've said might turn you into this
caricature of the one thing it doesn't
help but I think people become afraid
because unless you have a forum where
you can sit down and discuss you sort of
long form what you mean then it becomes
dangerous I think that's precisely why
podcasts like this do quite well because
I think you have enough time to have a
proper detailed discussion about what
you mean there is I think the rest of
the time we're trying to do this in 160
characters or less and you simply can't
you can't get to the essence and the
nuance and the difficulties with these
discussions in forums like that and you
have something like this actually I mean
YouTube if you go and you do on the
YouTube after when we put this episode
out you will see that there are some
people who absolutely go for it in that
way they will listen to the hour they
will go well forty minutes was really
interesting but this thing I really
didn't agree with or whatever which is
great right well there will also be
people now I think are so trained in
that kind of Twitter mentality that they
will go they will listen to one minute
and then they will pick something they
don't like and then comment about that
and not watch the rest of the
conversation I think that's scary well
it's not only scary it's it's again it's
intellectually dishonest it's bad
science you know you can't
take you know something out of context
you know and again I kind of go back
through the way that you see people
clinically you know one of the things
when you know when I work with someone
that's depressed I say one of the things
that a depressive mind does is it looks
for things to be sad about so you're
gonna look at new stories that are sad
you can look at something that's going
on in the street that may shed you
selectively find it if you're looking
for something to be offended by if
you're looking that's again that's
that's that's not the healthiest way to
to relate to the world around you you
know you need to look at things in you
know in the wider context look at what
was being discussed and then make you
know make that assumption what do you
think this comes from Sarah Francis what
do you think this increased
vulnerability increased kind of pursuit
of victimhood almost what do you think
where that comes from
I think I think partly because so many
obstacles I think were kind of taken
away from young people I think there is
this fear I think there's a genuine fear
that I won't be able to cope if you say
something I don't like I won't be able
to cope because I've not had to before
so I think people aren't used to it I
think also that there's there's value in
it that they get something so you you
know being being in the sick role
whatever that means means that you know
you're gonna be taking care of there's
gonna be special things put around you I
also think that again if we look at the
research on this so there's all this
research to this is increasing in
university campuses actually it's not so
much it hasn't really increased what's
happened is that people are pandering to
the minority more that's what's happened
so on university campuses where we see
since I think about 2013 we've been
seeing this whole kind of trigger
warning I know you can't have free
speech I think what's happened is it's
we've seen sort of university
administrators kind of take over and
pander to the loudest most offended
voice so you know I think sometimes
we're misrepresenting sort of younger
people in Millennials you know as being
this kind of puh
they're these terrible snowflakes I just
think what's you know what's happening
is that the minorities that that get
offended extremely easily and want to
shut down conversation have that have
been given you know much bigger forms to
be able to do and there's there's some
literature to attest to that there is
actually a reason for that which is the
the faculty has become far more
culturally left leaning over the
so the ratio used to be in the 60s it
would be like one conservative for like
ten liberals and now it's like one for
300 yeah we have a guy called coming in
to speak to us called Eric Coffman he
was a professor of politics later and he
there's something he talks about in this
book that just how that has changed over
time and also universities their self
selective as well as something that
people John Hiatt talks about this is
people go to university or liberal
anyway yeah and then if you've got
basically all very liberal professors
that will happen and that minorities
being pander to and I think one of the
things that Jonathan Hyde speaks about a
lot as well as this idea that we need
some diversity of thought you know this
leaders heterogeneity because you know
we if we're just bouncing off and saying
the same things over and over again it
you know obviously is gonna amplify that
one you know one idea one notion we all
seem to want diversity in more and more
from what I can see and we just were
talking about diversity but we don't
seem to want diversity of law especially
diversity that challenges our own
opinions because what seems to happen at
this point is shutting down no you're
wrong let's smear you as whatever x y&z
yeah yeah and and it's something to be
really and rightfully afraid of you know
I think a lot of people fear that
because it's just easier to not do your
homework and assume that that person
said that thing and because these ideas
spreads so quickly people are much more
likely as you said earlier the kind of
thing called you know what maybe it's
better if we don't but then you have to
ask yourself the question well what
happens if we continue not to you know
isn't it precisely the thing that we
fear the most this idea of you know yeah
big brother of someone watching you you
know we're watching each other now this
is late you know and that's kind of the
really worrying thing that we're
watching each other to catch each other
out to tell on each other
that doesn't make for like a happy
Society right and it's fine if you're
you know if we if we disagree if you're
like well you know you got this wrong
you know about this but I need to enter
into it with the idea that we're not all
coming from a place of being bad people
you know we're all trying to trying to
get to a better place of understanding
when you know when I work with couples I
always say look
if you have an argument you know move it
from between you and put it in front of
you and sit down and try and figure it
out together it's one of the best
techniques you know to do that and the
whole point of an argument is not to win
it it's to get to a better place of
understanding if we approach these
political arguments like that that I'm
not trying to you know Tring into left
and right and you know Democrat and
Republican yeah sure but orange face
popped into my head you know instead if
we were trying to have you know proper
discussions about understanding each
other better without calling each other
names and vilifying each other then
maybe we'd get somewhere but you you
know it very sadly I think you know you
see too many times it turns into this
name-calling and then that just that
doesn't help that I think that's where
the social media comes into because so
many times I can I used to have
arguments with people on Facebook all
the time about politics and always kind
of thing and I've really started but in
when I used to I I talk to that person
online and we'd have a disagreement and
they wouldn't go anywhere and the next
time I saw that person in person we
could have a conversation and sometimes
you find out you don't even have a
disagreement and that to me is a big
indicator but I mean we're increasingly
that's how we communicate but what
constitutes trying to say with that is
that he's a massive troll indefinitely
but but that face-to-face communicative
ace communication that makes us more
able to have the conversation because
face-to-face is not you know people
think that verbal communication is about
what's being said that's a small
proportion of it it's about body
language it's about inflection of voice
it's about you know I know when you're
ready to speak it's it you know think
about when we're speaking right you know
what I'm about to finish and you know
when to come in we don't say it to each
other but we just it's that that rhythm
now all of this together right the
context the body language the inflection
all these nuances means that you get a
lot more so if I'm if you were to say to
me don't be ridiculous Linda looking at
me and speaking I could get take it as a
joke if you tweet me you're being
ridiculous or don't be ridiculous I
don't see you kind of smiling I don't
see that and they know in the backdrop
we've had this great conversation so it
automatically we know without all that
call
texts I can take it differently and
again we've had you know I have this
great slide that I show this talk that I
did there's about kind of there's
something called ultimate I think is it
ultimate social penetration something
like that so it's about 50 million users
right when something reaches 50 million
users
I think the radio took something like 38
years and I think the TV took 20 years
and I think you know you go lower and
lower so the you know the the internet
took you know five years and mobile
phones took three years and Angry Birds
took 35 days you gotta remember that you
know these are all different ways of
communicating so through the radio we
had this great big span of time the TV
phones you know you know all of a sudden
not only am I not seeing you I'm trying
to figure out you know what what these
emojis mean you know you're sending me
various you know faces and I'm trying to
figure those out it's it's not something
that happens you know overnight and yet
it feels like it has and I think we're
still playing catch-up and so that's why
communication so much harder in some
ways I also think it's about threat of
force if you're talking to someone face
to face some of the stuff that people
will say to us online they would never
say that to your face cuz they probably
get punched in the face what's like
being inside a car now you scream at
people all the time when you're inside
your car ah I mean never someone like
you bumped into you on the road you
wouldn't be like what the hell are you
do you better go come here by all means
why do we do it's the same thing we feel
protected we feel so yeah but isn't it
also as well that we carry around this
latent anger straight at things a mentor
in our lives we get resentments we get
and all of a sudden somebody says
something online you're in your car and
it's just a way of venting of projecting
of a sense of release valve isn't it
really yeah yeah it's a release valve
age I don't have to see how much I've
upset you
I can then turn it off and go make a cup
of tea and forget about it you know and
it becomes you know a way of lashing out
with no consequence or potentially no
consequence so yeah I think it is I
think it's a really ineffective one I
don't think you know people should
construe that as an effective way
because I you know
these things you know thoughts aren't
intangible things you know you think
enough negative stuff it of course it
affects you we know now psycho
physiologically it affects you so I
think you know people that that carry
around that much anger and and hurt and
stuff you know kind of venting it and
putting it out there is is not a way of
properly dealing with it while it might
in the short-term feel like huh event
you know it's the stuff still there's on
a serious note you know if people you
know people really need to look at
themselves if they're doing that alright
well let's wrap up the social media
section with a positive message so if
you were to give some advice to people
who feel like maybe social media usage
is starting to become a problem for them
what can people do to kind of win
themselves off that um you know I I
think I think you need to understand
social media is a press release right
it's sort of their press releases about
our lives and we all do it so there's
all this really interesting research
that we post and are on a high and we
surf when we're on a low right so we
post and we're out in Michelin star
restaurant and we surf when we're eating
leftovers so remember that so you know
read it as a press release these are the
superlatives of each other's lives try
and use it to connect but also remember
that the proper connections that you
make actually you know they don't care
you know about what you're reading what
you're wearing what's going on so kind
of this you know that these propers the
things that nourish us nourish us the
most you know in terms of humor
interactions don't have to do with
people liking us if they have to do with
people liking us because just because
right so foster those relationships use
it you know you know for fun but I
certainly wouldn't say don't base your
self-esteem on and certainly don't base
you know the sense of self-worth on the
other
[Music]
you've done a lot of work Linda moving
on with how our mental health is
reflected in our skin and the way we are
would you be able to expand on that a
little bit sure so um so the skin and
the central nervous system actually
really closely related they develop part
of the same stuff embryologically they
acted germ which means that many times
we see that our stress levels the way
that we feel kind of manifest in skin
conditions if we have a predisposition
to them and this is something that I
studied for quite a while and and I
looked at the extent to which our
emotions affect the onset and
progression of different conditions and
we found that they very much do I kind
of think that you know again going back
you know our thoughts aren't in tangible
things if I sit around feeling very
stressed and very anxious a lot of
things are gonna happen in my body
physiologically so I know let's give the
example of a pimple right you get a
pimple right before the big day that
you're waiting for right before the date
or right before the you know the big
interview what happens we know that when
you get stressed your cortisol rises we
also know that testosterone is likely to
rise when you get stressed when
testosterone Rises we know that sebum
production Rises we know when sebum
production Rises you're much more likely
to get a clogged pore and boom you get a
pimple on the big day so there's a way
of understanding how your skin reacts to
stress and if you can clock it if you
can clock how your stress affects the
way that your skin develops and and the
health of your skin then you can work
towards making it better so we did a
study years ago my actually got into
this cuz my cousin had a bit of like oh
and she struggled with it for four years
and we looked at vitiligo and and we
were able to have significant reduction
through talking therapies right so out
of this it would see sir there will be a
reduction in these talking therapies
with CPT was a CBT protocol that
basically looked at how to deal with
stressful life situations and since then
some of my amazing doctoral students who
now have
in dermatology units have over doing
brilliantly waiting times or dermatology
infants are falling because so much of
the way that our skin the way that its
functions has to do with what's going on
in our minds but also what goes on our
minds has to do with how our skin looks
remember if you have a skin disease
people feel that they're able to ask if
you're walking around with an ulcer no
one can see it if you're walking around
with some eczema people will ask you
what's that or they'll look at it oh
there'd be kind of anxious to take
something from your hand that has an
effect on you so being able to mitigate
those effects by using good you know
technique psychological techniques
really helps we found why do why do why
is it that whenever I get stressed I get
eczema immediately that's the first
thing and it's always the same place so
where's the back of the legs and it's
just a disc and I can feel it the moment
I get anxious it starts with the itching
and then before I know it there's a
flare-up and again so you have your bone
the predisposition to attacks a mind the
stress ensures that the the kind of the
mechanisms through which our eczema
comes about are triggered right so what
would be really useful for you is if you
know that something is coming on so you
know if you can understand why that
stress is coming on is it work is it
you know too much on your plate but you
know what would be really great rather
than waiting till it gets that on a
serious notice to kind of say okay I
know these next three weeks are gonna be
really tough right so know what am I
gonna do what are the things that allow
me to feel better and for you know it's
different things are different people
some people meditate some people
exercise some people just speak to
friends you know but do it it's a you
know I always say to my patients it's
amazing how much time you know we make
in our Diaries from work we very rarely
put in time for for our physical health
and you need to take it as seriously as
that I know this is a crazy next three
weeks and this is what's gonna happen
I'm gonna take some time out to ensure
that I'm okay and hopefully you'll find
that kind of helps with that the
self-care it was a Gandhi that said
normally I meditate once a day when I'm
busy I meditate twice a day howdy
I think it was kind of someone someone
wise and old and do you guys meditate I
do do you know that these like and sound
machines they have like binaural sounds
and like light vision goggles that kind
of they simulate the experience of
meditation so I do that just by going to
the gym no it's amazing going to the gym
how actually your mental and physical
health completely changed it did its way
it's almost like a therapy session that
you're going in something you come out
and your sense of perspective about your
problems inverted commas whatever
they're maybe Sunday they they don't
seem as insurmountable absolutely well I
think there's something meditative even
in working out right you have to focus
but you're just running and focusing on
your breathing or lifting or whatever it
is so you're in there and now so all
this noise and I think that's the other
thing you know there's so much going
around you know you need to curate your
consciousness right there's a lot of
junk fair right whether it's the trolls
online or whether it's the worry that
you're not doing enough or whatever it
is so having a place whether it's
meditating with the gym where it's just
about that I think is hugely beneficial
actually you made me think about
something I played basketball regularly
and it's something I've noticed
basketball is very physical very
competitive sport you know you hit
people you get hit it's very like that
and one of the things I noticed every
time I'm driving to the core I find like
and this is maybe a man thing or maybe
it's just a constant something I wanted
to ask you what that's about is like I
feel myself like when I'm at home with
my wife I'm very gentle I'm very calm
etcetera but what I'm driving to
basketball I feel like almost like a
hard shell that I'm kind of closing up
Rea for that fight what is what is that
about is there a theory that explains
this well it looks so much of our
behavior situation-specific right so you
know different you the idea that were
different people in different situations
of course you're gonna see you know be
different at home than you are there so
clearly whatever those kind of
expectations those triggers are have to
do with kind of being competitive with
found of being hyper masculine and and
that works for you in that situation so
what you're doing is you're kind of
preparing for that
remember a friend of mine that worked in
addiction for a long time saying to me
that the vast majority of overdoses tend
to happen in places where people aren't
used to shooting up and she said because
the minute that you shoot up in a
different place you don't have those
visual cues right so you're having the
visual cues of I'm in the car got my
shorts on I've got the music so you're
you know you're it's Pavlovian right and
it's the same thing when you don't have
those visual cues you know you you act
differently listen I was gonna ask you
about the talk about skin but I imagine
that this psychosomatic effect goes way
beyond again I'm sure it affects
everything what about things like cancer
and things like is that something that's
affected by your mental state there's
there's a huge amount of research to
suggest that even things like wound
healing are affected by your mental
state recovery after might my dad had a
heart operation years ago and I remember
that's amazing work being done at UCL
around journaling and and wound healing
recovery and just kind of the ability
just to kind of say this is what I did
today and this is what was good about
the day or bad some amazing results so
we know absolutely in almost every realm
this idea that the minds you know here
in the bodies here it's not true you
know the two are connected you know and
it's not mumbo-jumbo it's not kind of
think yourself better and it'll be great
it's it's much deeper than that we're
trying to you know now we're kind of
finding the mechanisms that actually
translate into what it means into how
your immune system works or is
compromised and - you know how love
differing levels of hormones affect the
way that your body body repairs itself
or or inflammation or whatnot to wrap up
I wanted to move because on to
depression it's on a high but because
this I talk to a lot of people about you
know about mental health especially
because when I'm in comedy and everybody
seems to have a mental health issue and
comedy otherwise why would you be on a
stage telling jokes to people what are
you just funny in that room yeah but you
wouldn't feel the need to get up on
stage seeking affirmation from strangers
I hate to break it to you what is it
different between being a bit down and
having depression and at what point
should you seek help from somebody I'm
so glad you asked that
I think we kind of in our society we use
words like I'm anxious or I'm depressed
and and we think you know it means
depression and anxiety actually the you
know depression is there's a
quantitative difference so yeah we all
know what it feels like to be low but
when you speak to someone who's going
through sort of serious depression there
is a huge sense of overwhelming
hopelessness and helplessness the basics
you know I'm gonna get up in the morning
and take a shower feel like I'm gonna
you know climb a mountain you begin to
isolate socially it affects your sleep
it affects the way that you eat it
affects your libido
so it's like an all-encompassing thing
so this idea that people are like oh if
you're depressed just you know snap out
of it you know and I thank goodness
we're kind of moving away from that but
you know I think part of that's happened
because we all know what it feels like
to be down right and to be down you know
even when you're really down you kind of
know that this will pass there's a part
of you that knows when you're seriously
depressed there's a big part of you
thinks that this will never pass not
only it won't it pass that somehow this
is a character flaw in me that won't
pass I think that's one of the saddest
things about depression that there's no
sense of entitlement over it in their
way that there would be over any other
illness you know so you know God forbid
someone has you know cancer I'm asked
there's like a sense of you know I have
this and I'm gonna fight it and it's
gonna be with depression it's like yeah
but really everyone's depressed is it
you know is it just me and I you know if
I think if people hear nothing else they
need to feel a sense of entitlement over
their mental health the way that they do
or their physical health because well
that's the only way to get the support
that you need and when we know that its
immense it's a very big killer the way
that a lot of physical illnesses are
well as a slight counter point that to
that I know for myself right that I can
vary and maybe I'm misusing the word
depression but I can create for myself
an experience of depression whatever
that is very easily I just need to knock
out the house not do any exercise not go
out with me hang out with Francis always
helps not do any exercise right not not
go out the house not spend any time with
my wife
not spend time with friends played too
many computer games maybe drink too much
alcohol right if I do five or six things
for a period of two weeks I will be
feeling like like you just described
guaranteed and how much of it is within
our control there is the possibility of
the self-care that you've talked about
to make ourselves better sure look I
think that there's definitely things
that you can do to make yourself better
and make yourself feel worse right we
know that depression has a genetic
element right so now I always say you
can win with a losing car a card and and
lose with a winning card right so even
if you have a winning card I feel like
you're saying you're kind of socially
isolating and drinking and not kind of
you know exercising you can very easily
feel awful the difference is is that for
people who who experience sort of kind
of serious depression is that it's just
it's a it's a lot harder and and then
they need some support to get it so
there's a qualitative different student
and we believe that it's just it's
harder to shift so it's not to say and I
want people listening again there's
absolutely things you can do but if
they're not working for you and they're
working for everyone else doesn't mean
that you're doing them wrong it just
means you have more serious form of
depression Linda's been absolutely
fantastic thank you so much for coming
to talk to us the question we always
like to ask our guests at the end is is
that one issue that we know one talks
about that we ought to be talking about
or maybe just something we haven't
covered in the interview that you think
is important to talk about um I guess I
guess I think for me at the moment I
think we need to be talking about how
the development of artificial
intelligence is going to affect not just
what we're gonna do economically but
socially as a group because I think it's
gonna come perhaps a lot quicker than
people expect it's already starting to
have some effects on us and I think we
just need to have so more serious
conversations about how to protect our
kids and ourselves and what kind of
thing are you talking about
you said that specifically when you talk
about AI and things like that well I
think already it's affecting the job
market so you you've got kids who are
looking for jobs that won't exist by the
time that you know they're out of you
know high school and university who are
in their teens now so I think you know
that's gonna be a really big obstacle
for governments when you have you know a
lot of joblessness we know that
joblessness and and you know poor mental
health go hand in hand we know that it's
already an issue I you know and I think
with the advent of automation which is
happening more and more it's gonna get
worse and I just think we need to really
think about it not just in terms of
economics but in terms of sort of our
societies or society's mental health you
know we're kind of collective sometimes
what does this mean because a sense of
purpose is very important and I don't
think necessarily you have to make X
amount of money to have a sense of
purpose but you need to kind of figure
out what you have to offer and where you
belong and and you know I think that
before that sneaks up on us we just need
to have the right conversations and you
have a podcast which is called the
psychology behind that's right and then
you cover different topics and it's all
very kind of positive change focused I
think from what I've seen it's really
about how do you be happy how do you do
this right tell us a little bit about
that yeah so it's basically we take did
a recent research is a very short
podcast 15-20 minutes we take a study
out about you know how do I deal with
shyness how do I deal with failure how
to become happier oh good for you man
and we are we are we analyze the
research and we kind of use it into
actionable tips sort of the five things
you can do today to help you everybody
subscribe perfect and you're on twitter
at at dr. linda underscore p perfect
we'll put that in the in the video as
well thank you so much for coming on to
conclude if you enjoyed it guys
subscribe as always I click that build
button next to subscribe button we are
on Twitter and Instagram on Facebook all
these terrible social media platforms
that please keep using them and here's a
polite channel that trigger pod and if
you enjoyed it we'll see you in two
weeks time with another brilliant
episode thanks for much thanks guys
[Music]